the reviews are in for hunter's art
career former obama white house ethics
chief tearing into the first
son's plan to sell his paintings for
prices up to a half
million that's one of them
[Laughter]
the notion of a president's son
capitalizing on that relationship by
selling art at
obviously inflated prices and keeping
the public in the dark about who's
funneling money to him
has a shameful and gritty feel to it
hunter's not the only
member family member cashing in
relatives of key white house officials
have landed jobs in the administration
but jen
sackey says there's nothing to worry
about
we have the highest ethical standards of
any administration in history
number of ethics officials have conveyed
that um and we're proud of that
dan can you argue that hunter's
paintings are designed to keep his nose
clean
because that's why he uses straws you
get painted it they can't put it up your
nose
i mean that could be that might be a
part of you know that's how you beat
your habit
dana i loved doing blow art yes
i did as a kid that was one of the best
things that vacation bible school we
would do that's
so fun um vacation bible study what's
vacation by middle school
you went to people i did too what are
you talking about we're the weirdos here
jesse we didn't go to the vacation
summer time and sometimes christmas
holiday
there's a good week where you go to like
a camp every day it's vacation bible
school
and you get to do like crafts and
activities like and learn about
art and learn the beatitudes yeah maybe
we should have gone to that
yes i think i think there's a hole in my
life vacation bible school
was awesome uh the last thing i'll say
on this is responding indignantly
to questions about ethics in regards to
the president's son or
um you know other situations is kind of
uh ironic given that they
really ran against president trump based
on his epics
their perceived view of how quickly they
forget
dana how quickly they forgot dagan uh
you know
uh what's wrong with selling art based
on your notoriety isn't that just kind
of like an autograph
no if your father is in the white house
and you have a history of
questionable at the very least behavior
a year and a half ago nobody even knew
this loser was an artist until the
new york times wrote this glowing
profile of him at just as the pandemic
was taking off but they went to pulitzer
for the coronavirus coverage
there's a new artist in town the name is
biden
was the title of it and they talk about
oh the paint stained
forearms and fingers and the black and
red
deep under his nails so now he's selling
these things or trying to for half a
half a million dollars i'd say that of
that price 90 percent is bribery maybe
10 is for the paint but nobody now is
going to buy this
dreck because they're going to have
their background looked into
like you're going to get a
ring-a-ding-ding from the fbi or justice
yeah maybe he slips coke into the canvas
that's a great way to get it over the
porous border
richard the one thing about nepotism i
think that
we could agree on is that it hurts
minorities because
what you're already laughing at how do
minorities get into this because
because white people have the jobs
that they can just hire their cronies
no we're talking about nepotism well
listen i minorities are hurt most by
nepotism because they aren't in the
power structure
to give the jobs to their kids in france
i think that's in the bill and
the iowa bill yes fair enough look i
listen i i think that um you know i
don't think that hunter should be
selling
paintings and listen i also think that
in this particular moment as we talk
about hunter biden it's worth pointing
out that there is still a pending
justice investigation that is going
unharmed untouched by the marin garden
justice department against hunter biden
which speaks to the fact that this the
joe biden and he believes in this ideal
of an independent justice system
and a justice department and that's how
and that's happening and with that being
said
it's also worth pointing out that
there's no biden people that work in the
white house unlike the trump white house
where
everybody their point was that though
that there are a couple there are a few
people who are couples that are
appointed in the white house that often
happens you meet in washington you stay
in washington you know yeah
that's the swamp damn i wanted to hire
peter when i coined the phrase swamp
that's what i was talking about we need
to drain that swamp
jesse i i don't know if selling art is a
bad thing because i have a feeling you
and i are going to be doing this very
in the next 10 years we're going to be
doing blow yeah blue hearts yes
or vacation bible school right we should
probably do both
one before the other so do you consider
me a petty person gutfeld
perhaps would you mind if i acted a
little petty oh please do
last week i said on this very show
that hunter selling his little blow art
to i don't know a russian billionaire
for a half a mill
was violating the spirit of campaign
finance and
potential i don't know laundering laws
bribery statutes whatever now
did that make waves no then let's
the ethics expert for joe biden says it
and everyone goes oh really well perhaps
we should look into this
it doesn't take an expert to realize
this is a scam
yeah do i need a new title yes is fox
host not enough for people to pay
attention yeah maybe ethics
i mean do i have to go to law school for
people to listen to me it's clearly a
scam
why does an expert have to tell you and
then everybody says oh yeah it's a scam
i said it when you look at those
paintings
just look at those paintings you realize
that it looks like
i don't know i don't know why you spent
a moment well i was waiting for them to
throw one up there but it just looks
like that like it looks like a leftover
from a smurf orgy
why would you spend a million bucks on
that i just don't understand yeah well
that's what it is it's
well you don't understand richard all
right the fastest hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else